Arena welcome uh back to the show a
difficult game today with the white
pieces against arisley you know her so
well you've played two matches in last
year's Edition you started off with a
win both of those matches today a much
different story tell us about that yeah
well we had a kind of pan-off variation
that quickly
got into something that I think neither
of us were very familiar with I was um a
little surprised here by the move G6
when she refused to capture the pawn
back
um and refused to take on yeah right so
G6 of course it's you know kind of it's
a move that makes sense it exists and
then it's kind of like a hybrid right
because normally white would be having
like a Pawn on D4 in these positions you
know because to keep the D5 Pawn white
is often you know playing Queen A4 check
right so basically it seems like
logically the G6 would not be as good
because I didn't even have to commit my
queen to A4 to keep this Pawn okay so I
played Bishop C4 then the one thing I
wasn't so sure about is word by night
should go instead of yeah E3 or F3 right
like I kind of was second guessing
myself I mean I I mean of course I
played it to E2 because I had some
thoughts that like it would go to F4 one
day protect the pawn but then I realized
it really didn't need to I didn't need
my knife for that like I could always
just go Queen B3 so maybe the Knight
could have gone to F3 but okay 92 92 is
one of the main moves Knight F3 sure
maybe a bit more uh games in the
database but 92 is a very decent move as
well castle Yeah Castle the Knight D3 is
like I mean here I was you know pretty
happy I was like okay have an extra Pawn
um
not clear how she's gonna play she came
up with this interesting plan of A6 and
B6 right and the thing is like I was I
was definitely aware of these B5 ideas
like in the game and the game would look
like I just kind of blundered it which I
I kind of did but I also was aware of
these ideas and I mean I have to say
like yeah I wasn't so impressed with my
play in this part like like H3
um yeah before it felt like it was a bit
off well I did age three in order to
play Bishop F4 and not have like Knight
H5 so maybe because of Bishop yeah maybe
I should have gone for that I'm trying
to remember so what made me change my
mind that was one of the main lines
Bishop to E3 was also a very good move
for the same idea with B5 yeah it
doesn't come with as much power with the
pawn on D3 yeah D4 I mean I was trying
to restrict that night but honestly I
walked right into B5 and that did not
feel good because I knew actually well
like that here I just had to hold the
game because you know how you get the
sense of danger it's like I knew this
was not this is not a position that uh
you know white is veteran despite the
extra opponent it's a position you gotta
just hope that you can neutralize
Black's activity and I mean she has the
D5 Square the play against the d-pawn
and my B Pawn is just completely
irrelevant so like you know from this
point on I was just trying to be very
careful to not let my position
deteriorate
um and you know fortunately I wasn't you
know really made and it's not like you
you didn't yeah now one question
considering Knight takes what was your
response yeah Queen A4 was your plan
yeah and actually I was a little
surprised by Bishop D5 that she let me
you know have Knight F4 with Tempo
um but I thought I was like oh maybe
she's like you know playing for a win
like this because she doesn't want to
allow Queen A4 which seems like it's
going to force the queen trade and I
probably could equalize right like I was
something like that Basics yep it should
be three and in kind of petering out to
a draw so I did think that her decision
was interesting even if it did leave the
Knight on B6 kind of not in the best
position did you feel at this point that
she was trying to play for more I mean
it depends on I guess it depends exactly
what she's thinking and playing this
move because she was saying that she
played the on Bishop D5 she was actually
surprised by Knight F4 so then I can
understand why she played it because
she was saying that she thought like
Knight F4 would eventually get hit with
G5 and I would have problems on G2 but
you know after rookie one it didn't turn
out that way so then in a way then maybe
what was the problem with yeah well I
could go like you know Knight age five
and I mean it's also very double-edged
yeah like here I mean okay I was gonna
say that not only Knight G7 there's even
Queen G4 is a move that you can look at
um I mean so it definitely is dangerous
yeah it doesn't feel like black is the
one playing for anything here so she she
couldn't go for these ideas and that
means kind of well you see I never
wanted to put my Pawn on F3 right
because it's just so ugly so ugly to put
that pawn there weaken the E3 Square the
D4 Pawn would check
um so this way at least I got to play
carefully I see the computer likes my
Bishop F1 oh he does it it certainly so
careful yeah
I mean we were looking at after the game
with her after this move Queen A4
instead of Bishop takes E3 because I was
thinking it's like her only chance I can
show you the line that we looked at and
see what the computer was saying after
Bishop E3
yeah I thought like Queen A4 was
you know something that she could try to
make it a little bit unpleasant for me
and then there's this line so Queen
takes A4 Knight A4 Rook D1
and E5
and and here we looked at Knight E2
Knight takes B2 and Rook B1 like and we
were like looking at this position it's
kind of amazing because it looked like
white was holding on yes and white is
holding on yeah
Bishop takes D4 and it's going to be a
draw
so
um I mean but I would have had to kind
of find something make a few decisions
still after Queen A4 yeah it's also not
unclear that this is actually just a
draw yeah right
um but you know when she took on E3 then
I knew okay I was definitely out of
danger
um I was going to be able to move my B
Pawn up and she has to trade the knights
otherwise you know she might get some in
trouble yeah it felt like after this uh
after you missed this move B5 you kind
of set your mind on just equalizing and
pulling the brakes yep is that how you
felt as well and even towards the end
you didn't even try for more yeah well
it's hard to try from work because you
could lose you know
um I didn't I mean we can look it at the
end
um since we have so much time Christian
until the the match between uh Favi and
aronian resumes but like uh King I
thought she might try queen of Faith
here yeah Queen E5
Queen D6
and yeah well here I was planning to
trade the queens and I thought like okay
um it was more like I was thinking yeah
I was thinking could I be better could I
you know or not so I mean I'm not
surprised she didn't go for this one but
it's hard for me to to play for a win
when she has his diagonal and always F3
squared D5 square with the queen so
um it felt like a normal point to wrap
things up at absolutely now talk to us
about uh Alice Lee you know her from
last year what changed in this one year
period
oh well
experience
a lot
had a really good season in the protest
League you know playing against a lot
stronger players uh really successfully
um so you know I mean she was young and
talented a year ago and she's like young
and talented and more experienced now
after a year
um I mean it's nice to see her progress
I'm looking forward to her playing on
the Olympia team you know in Budapest in
2024 I think we definitely need some
young players joining the team
um and yeah I mean I'm also enjoying the
match with her and you know hopefully
we're gonna play even more exciting game
tomorrow you are the one Grand Master in
this competition do you feel like she
has Grand Master potential as well yeah
definitely of course yeah I mean if she
just keeps doing what she's doing and
playing at the at the rate that she's
playing at and just seeking out that
stronger competition and working on her
game I mean I don't see any reason why
in a few years she couldn't be a GM guys
join join the conversation we still have
a few minutes before the big match
starts oh first of all Irina I couldn't
agree with you more I think Alice Lee is
just one of the great talents of America
and watching her gain experiences you
said is marvelous I see her as a future
anchor of the Olympic team so definitely
uh all the way there so I would offer
you the advice of Victor Corson or beat
him while they're young
absolutely Jovi
yeah no I I didn't really have too many
questions for arena but uh
I'm kind of interested about how you
approach this tournament though as a
whole
oh how I'm approaching it okay that's
the question um
I mean I would say I approach it the
same way I approach all my tournaments
obviously I'm you know doing my best uh
trying to be
you know kind of clever in the
preparation what kind of um you know
openings I'm choosing against my
opponents you know and I feel like
overall I've played you know pretty
decently like a pretty decent level of
Chess you know this game seems a little
bit bad from you know compared to some
of the other ones I've played
um but on the other hand like even here
you know once I saw there was a problem
like you know I just kind of I mean I
was able to take care of it before it
devolved into anything serious you know
it's kind of like when you have a little
bit of a leak and you just you know plug
that leak and it doesn't get any worse
so from that point of view I think I did
my job in this game of course you know
it's a different story that I didn't
make anything of the white pieces you
know and completely um
played rather
you know lackadaisically for a couple of
moves there in the opening
um but you know okay there's there's
going to be a second game and hopefully
I'm just going to be able to like
play some good good chess now Irina
you're uh also a coach a teacher but you
also have a new YouTube channel oh is
that correct uh let's give it a shout
out what do you teach there all right
Christian yeah you're my my fellow
YouTuber yes you know I also watch your
channel Christian with uh with Fabiano
to get all the latest test news and um
yeah a couple of months ago I started my
channel it's actually like my first time
talking about it publicly like you know
the reference I made at the beginning of
the tournament as well but up until that
point I haven't even let people know
about it
um because I was just trying to add more
content do more videos and yeah so I do
use my coaching experience like really
because I you know work with people
every day so I get to see what are the
common mistakes mistakes and thinking at
this level that a lot of casual players
are at you know and and I try to
um you know focus on that in the video
so like every video has some sort of
instructive takeaway Point Irina thank
you very much we'll see you tomorrow
yeah
congratulations Arena good luck tomorrow
uh in your game